Et.
Les ordinateurs quantiques sont très sensibles au bruit,
des perturbations qui provoquent des erreurs
dans leurs calculs, mais de nouvelles recherches montrent
que les ordinateurs bruités d'IBM correspondent aux méthodes classiques exactes
et surpassent dans certains régimes des méthodes classiques sophistiquées
d'approximation, à la fois dans des régimes vérifiables
et dans des régimes hors de portée de la vérification.
Pour une expérience de simulation particulièrement difficile.
Comment font-ils ? Ils utilisent une technique spéciale
pour gérer le bruit
dans les systèmes quantiques : c'est ce qu'on appelle la mitigation d'erreurs.
Avec la technique de mitigation d'erreurs
utilisée dans cette expérience, on effectue nos calculs
en augmentant progressivement le niveau de bruit.
Ensuite, on extrapole jusqu'au niveau zéro de bruit.
Ce travail nous rapproche un peu plus de l'informatique quantique utile,
nous